welcome to this video playing great
master mandragora from Thailand I know
the flag this time it's a friend of mine
Grandmaster che block or teammate now
living in Thailand so let's see what can
I do here hmm now we have a huge number
of games played in the past I don't know
what he plays against this something
with Eva no not this time I think Bishop
g5 is the right see 5d 5v5 Bishop d3 is
how they play it should be three anyway
yeah looks like the right spot I have
tried 92 earlier and then again maybe
against them slavko cheat shocked as I
walk out not totally sure yeah black is
very flexible it can also go see 6 and
b5 okay so probably we get this gruene
fraud sorry this bangle style position
so I'm just castling or how to play I
don't particularly want to take at the
end is always this nightie for business
so probably just castling
I guess I guess you will take now 1c4
sometimes you can of course delay that
but I think now I'm really threatening
to take b5 and keep the pawn in a rather
favorable situation yeah okay this is
you can always insert we had to put this
piece
Bishop it's not so clear to me very
often bishop age 4 is offside but I'm
not not sure at the moment as it also
keeps some pressure on e7 yeah in this
situation for example it puts some
pressure on his heaven ok maybe here so
that I have a bishop f1 in case of 96
and getting a good spot for the for this
piece I want to get a lots of the look
outside of the long diagonal mmm
not-not-not this problem I'd ok it's not
a huge problem I can also play 92 here
to avoid the trades not sure that this
is any good down
don't know why would he take our plane I
deform okay 94 I can take Bishop takes
Queen takes h6o 94 probably not coming I
couldn't take twice on b5 sa2 what's I
was hey night it just might be 6 mm and
maybe this is an idea actually so that
maybe night III to see form can be can
be played
maybe night if III g4 looks weird but
maybe maybe an idea so get this out of
the range of the bishop
yeah should I play a 4 here try to to
block the whole thing maybe maybe 94
takes pawn takes yeah this is this is
now much better because the night comes
to see 5 mm this was bad hmm yeah this
was really bad judgment I forgot that he
take can take with the sea poem hmm very
ugly check
yeah if I get in Knight c3 be five it's
okay but i don't think i will manage
unfortunately because of this move d
three sm hanging a four is hanging nah
mmm that's very very very bad okay I
need to complicate matters him good good
or bad with it ok maybe not here to d3
can get this in
every time pushing to form gap okay
again maybe I need to need to get rid of
this Bishop somehow not sure that Bishop
t4 is even good but f-for rookie form
takes rook takes out at least he has
weakened the King slide a bit it's not
it's not good or anything for me but
maybe some swindling chances c5 is
hanging
i knowi five hmm not good
wow it's amazingly bad this position
that it's even with the check so even
with a check that's really know very
little hope of getting something in
rookie to it's not even a threat rook g7
dough is a threat maybe check check
check check I won't ever lose on time
probably check check white this was just
bad play wow I played this like a total
[ __ ] especially considering that this
position here is certainly quite good
for white the fairly typical benoni
structure where white is just better but
I really misplayed this dramatically the
main problem was that I didn't think
about when i played a for this is ok i
mean nothing great or anything but this
is just bad terribly bad i completely i
thought he must return to to c7 because
i simply fall for some reason didn't
consider that he can take with the pawn
um Jim if I play something like that I
mean what is black doing in this
position up a threat needy five I just
thought that I can play it more
conveniently my idea was a thought you
must return and after that I mean okay a
five hangs so this is a total
catastrophe the problem is that this is
just just very uncomfortable with the
night coming to see five yeah now as
those should do that probably this is
Jesus even even more problematic with
the route coming to before and now all
of a sudden the tables are turned now
black is far better the rock on before
is very strong and those two pawns on a
big weakness yeah I try to try to
confuse him basically but of course this
shouldn't shouldn't be successful dad
was it was just luck that I shot this in
G white is winning Shabazz but it does
not does not really matter the whole
game was was really bad my my my son you
know if I was just bad ever forgot about
cd4 if we look at this something like
this what what is black doing here if I
Visser is some is on the horizon and to
consider this in comparison no yeah I
don't have a weakness on b3 that's the
big difference and I'm threatening
long-term to just expand this is very a
very good benoni relief with them very
limited counter play for black ok thanks
for watching